THIOM JAKE TAPPER.PRESIDENT VOL
ZELENSKYY BEED. LAWMAKS AY ITS I
SUPPORT TO HELN TARY
ABOUT THAT
CALL AND THE U.S.
UKRAINE, THE VICE CHAI THE
CMI U US.
YOL WITH PRESIDENZE
WHAT WAS THE MEETING LIKE?
YOU?
>> I TNKED THE
REEDTHPUBLIC.
OBVIOUSLY TH W GE
SUPPOIVOFD COG TO DO.THERCOMPLM
THEMTHE G, THE AVE LAUNCH BETWET
IN THEKRAINE.A PART OF TH
TO D P MOVE THLANES.
SO NEITHER SIDREUSSIAN APORTY
GHT
R IT. EVERYONE TO
MAGOLTHERE H .  TWEETED VOTTOFR
NOT ARNG
MEUN
ENDEISUE FSTF ALL,T  MLL AFTER I
IT.
HERE ARE OVER 300 PEOE  THAT NE
L  BEETHERE WAS NOG SECURE ABOU
PIE,HESEEN.
THISK POSED.
LLS HAVE SEB
WANTS THEIR NAME MENTIONED I
THE PRESS.
>> RUSSIA CAPTURED THE KEYITOF C
WESTERN INTELLIGENCFICIAL SAYS,
QUOTE, BBA CITIES INTO SING T
NEXT FEW DAY
RENY C
LIVES? RIGHT NOW
>> OBVIOUS, IFHERE'S MOVE CIVILS
NNOCENTSOS
OF IS AN OF HOE  KEEP THEIR
WORD.EY DALLO
CORRIRSI WORRY
EYING IT FCAN ATTACK THAT
AND ARGUE HA THE UKRAINIANS DID
CT
I ASK PEOPLEO LOT E
IM OF WHATN
THEY T POPION
INTO EIT IS A TAIC UE
NORTRNAR THE COUNTRY.  ESPECIAL
>> TWEETED YOU'T
OUGH HOW MUC
ANRICHANGED.
REN FE OANANOU THINK THE WESTE
GETTING M TO AT LEAST
>> FIRSTT ME SLLY 'S
TO THIS INVASION IY AT
I'PLE NOT
MOS, INCLUDINGING.
THE UKRAINIAN GO
OF THE COURI
DI BD INVADE.
WHATT RECOGNIZE IS
IIS GUY IS ALMOST 7S OLD.S
LETE UNLESS HE
RESTORE TEIA WHICH LAS
TO INCLUDE UKRAINE AT B, IF NO.
ANG
ASSERTIONS TO THEMTHR
AS A RESULT YOU SEE A PERSON ATF
WHERE HE'S EITHER GOING TO HAVE
Y VICTOROWED BY A  OCCUPATION
THE SAMEOR HE'S  CAUGHT IN
S AN ECONOMY FREE N HIS OWN
THCO TWO
THINGS I THINK PUTS USRY
DANGEROUS PLACHAS GOINSOMETHINGE
M WORR THOSE
BE. N THURSDAY, YOUR RLICOLLEAY
GRAHAM OF SOUTH CAROLINA OPENLY
SSINATE PUTIN.
W A
RUSSSU
STAFF FEN BERGONLY WAY THIS ENDI
SOMEBODY TTAS GUY
YOU WOULD BE DR COUNTRY
AND THWOSERVICGREE WITH SENATOR
GRAHAM
E WATCHING THESE EING
MURDERED A SUFFERING.
YOE  METNGLAP.
TOOK THIS GUY AN I
ING ABU.S.CY HE UNITED STATES.
DOIN.
I WOULD SAY AT SOME POINT I DOT
PERE CHANCES  THAE
HIGH, HOPEFULLY TO STAND ES FORS
DONEFOR WHATTHER
SAYING I THIN
EXPRESSING THE FRUSTRATION THAT
T OF PEOPLE HAVE THATHHOING.
IT DOESN'T SEEM ANYT WY BRING AE
S  IT. VERATING FOLE ID LEGISLAB
SHOULD TR THATO ALREADALTHPRIC?
GET EVEN WORSE TO STAND UP T
>> FIRST LETY THE
CT
ING.NG RSIILT HAVING L WOULD RAS
THAT PROVES THATUT
IC
TO RAISE GASY METS.
WE SHOULDN'TOW TINUE.
WE SHOULDN'T ALLOW VLADIMITHAT O
AMERICANS BYTIF SOMEOIUTURE.
WE SHOD D
AND THE TIME W THE CUTOFANUR S
RESERVES FOR
PELL DTHADS
THAT THEY CONTINUE TO E TO  TO
NDR AND THIS MURDEROUS
UNDERTAKI.
RUSSIECEXPERT FIOL SAID FANCHG.
SAID, QUOTE, FACT THAT  MANAGEDT
FOS INFORMATION WAR.OR SUC
S
TY, NOT JUST
SOE  AS ON
THE RIGHT.ES OF THE  PUBLIYIGOO
BLAMING THS OM
YOU'VE MADE A INT,
WEEKS O  EXPLAIN TFLORIA, THAM
CAREAI EVI
THINKOUTOEC IONA HYS
ARE DOING HIS JOB HIM?
>> THERE ARE NOTOPLE
TALKING THAT WAY
I THINEO
FULLUNDERSTAND WHAT THIS WAS
THE'
VOICES ANTERVIEWS.
R  THEREE
PEOPLRE ARGUINGHYINE TO D THEY
NE NAT
CAN AVOID ALL .
THAT WAS NEVERE.T T TO SS
WAS NEVER TRUETHIS IS A COUNTED
AND , TO GT
THERAND
CORP A
FEIV LOOK AT THE NUMBERSW
UKRAF ACUTIN
IS